I
Look up there. That's a big bird. Yeah, what do you think that is I don't know maybe it's a
Lady's a crow babies ah
seven hours wait a minute smell that
this muscle except
Millsap
[team] basketball
You stand before wardell Stefan curry of house Golden state second of his name fresh prince
baby-Faced Assassin
sinker of threes and brother of Splashes
Don't be afraid my friend the king says you may approach and speak
as Zona De Defensa
[Terra] Want the the City Pika [their] sword an he is a denver nugget
He says he prayed [for] your victory against the pelicans. [I] thank him [for] his prayers O
Prinstone
officer
Back to rare Possessors war lay up it was your crossover. He says it
broke his ankles
There's another [table] this one suits me fine
don't worry, not interested [I]
Just want the season to be over you swore a solemn vow remember you supposed to help me win a championship
[I] didn't intend to get hurt chemistry Matters Kevin stop trying to find a way to fit out
and just fit in
Be a part of something special [just] [my] thoughts
They call [you] big man
[you] lost friend
forgive me for staring I
Don't see many Clippers where I am from
You know I don't see many rocket men in the city of angels. [we] don't like the smog
Come with me my beard now. Why are you wasting a center like this on a bush face choker?
Do you know why the whole world hates a clipper you think you're complaining? And you're acting tough makes you worth two billion gold
But you're just a whiny little baby who's far too slow on the flop